so maybe you saw this yesterday yeah
there's a piece on the Huffington Post
if you're if you're in the unfortunate
habit of reading The Huffington Post you
may have seen an article from Noah
Mickelson and what he's saying is that
we all have to stop eating at
chick-fil-a because it is pure bigotry
to eat a chick-fil-a okay now
here's the thing about that um sorry I'm
just finishing my lunch the waffle fries
I'm sorry
the waffle fries are very good they're
not the best fast-food fry however that
honor of course goes to what we all know
it goes to what Arby's right now
had to get lunch so
in fact you know the chick-fil-a that I
go through the line as always it's
always like gay there's always about 57
cars in the line but it's it's well
worth it that's pretty much every chick
full let you go to that it seems to me
it's the one fast food restaurant where
I mean like you go to a Burger King I've
never seen more than two cars in line at
a Burger King I've never seen it but a
chick-fil-a we were we were driving
through Pennsylvania the other day we we
stopped off at a chick-fil-a
and the line was so long the line itself
started in Connecticut that's how long
the line was literally now I think maybe
there's 10 cars in line but it was it
was a big line is the point anyway so
but what I'm doing right now is is is
very bad I'm not supposed to be doing
this want to read a little bit from this
article he says no Mickelson says if you
really love LGBTQ people then you are
not allowed to eat a chick-fil-a he says
when Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey was called
out earlier this week for tweeting about
eating at chick-fil-a during Pride Month
I don't know if you heard about that but
the CEO of Twitter ate at chick-fil-a
which was crime number one but crime
number two it was during Pride Month of
all times to eat at chick-fil-a how dare
he but he did issue an apology he issued
that he issued a formal apology for
having eaten at chick-fil-a that's
that's where we're at right now in our
culture anyway um so Mickelson goes on I
was shocked to see how many queer people
and their allies not only didn't care
what went out of their way to defend the
fast food chain excuses I've heard for
continuing to eat at chick-fil-a ranged
from a nonchalant dismissal to an
all-or-nothing paradigm to a simple
admittance that the siren song of the
company's kitchens has proven impossible
to ignore the siren song of chick-fil-a
I do it is a very enchanting song I have
to say to all of these flimsy
justifications I say bull s Laden say
yes he said the whole word if you care
about queer people or you yourself are
queer you have absolutely no business
eating at chick-fil-a ever it's really
that straightforward if you're arguing
that there are other arguably bigger
fish or in this case chicken to fry you
may not be wrong however I think you're
under estimating my and probably your
ability to be angry about and take
action against more than one target at
once
that's really healthy isn't it when your
goal is to be angry about at more than
one thing at the same time you're under
estimating your ability to be angry at a
lot of things all at once just because
chick-fil-a may not be as bad in your
view as the Trump administration that
doesn't mean we shouldn't challenge
chick-fil-a on its anti queer stance
while continuing to call out and work
against other offensive and/or dangerous
entities
chick-fil-a is a dangerous entity you're
looking right now into the this is that
you're looking at danger right here now
on Twitter The Huffington Post shared
this article and I could've just read
the whole thing because it's pretty
hilarious honestly but I won't do that
um havi to post shared the article and
added a similar rallying cry it said
it's time to choose where your loyalty
lies with the queer community or with
your stomach now this is a very bold
move to stack yourself up against a
chicken sandwich and ask people to
choose between the two I would never do
that okay I wouldn't even do that
like with my wife okay I would never say
hey listen honey it's me or this what's
it gonna be I would do I'd be way too
terrified about what the answer might be
so that but this is what the left is now
doing with the gay community they're
saying hey you can either have a gay
community or you can have chick-fil-a
what's it going to be and considering
the the gay left
has been frankly so vicious
um towards Christian conservatives it's
you know again I I don't know if that's
a competition you want to have um but
this is the stance that the that the
left has taken it refuses to coexist
alongside this chicken restaurant and it
will attempt to punish not only the
company but anyone who even associates
with the company it will try to punish
and it these efforts have not gone away
you know Eve we've got this stuff
happened this week you've got on college
campuses you always hear about any type
of chick-fil-a opens on a college campus
you have students that rally together in
protest
I mean I don't know why it's not like
many college campuses least the ones
I've been to there there's often often
times there are not very very many good
food options and your your rallying
against the best food option what's
wrong with you cutting off your nose to
spite your face or despite your stomach
in this case so you hear about that
there was that really bizarre article in
The New Yorker a few months ago where
they talked about the creepy insurgency
of chick-fil-a into New York City so
it's clear that the left has not
forgotten about Dan Cathy who's the CEO
of chick-fil-a has not forgotten about
his sin of publicly supporting biblical
marriage six years ago they have not
forgotten about that they will never
forget about that they have chosen the
hill they're going to die on and it is a
hill covered in chicken sandwiches and
waffle fries and chicken nuggets and
there's also milkshakes on the hill
especially the have you had the cookies
and cream milkshake at chick-fil-a very
good it's an above average milkshake and
I mean comparing it to even restaurants
that specialize in milkshakes and ice
cream anyway what were we talking about
oh yeah
chick-fil-a now
I think there there are two things that
we conservatives and Christians can
learn from this
from this whole you know what's been
happening with chick-fil-a in the left
war on chick-fil-a it's two things we
can learn from it one I wrote about
yesterday and and that it's an important
lesson that I've talked about before but
it's worth emphasizing never apologize
for your beliefs
if your beliefs are right and true never
apologize for them
dan cathy has never apologized for his
for his stance on traditional marriage
so-called traditional marriage so-called
biblical marriage when really it's just
marriage right but he's never apologized
for that six years later they're still
coming after him he still has not
apologized now the left could try to
claim some sort of victory based on the
fact that Dan Cathy's charitable
organization doesn't donate to certain
quote anti-gay groups anymore and di
Cathy's also a couple years after all
this went down he came out and said that
he regrets inadvertently getting his
company involved in a political dispute
he obviously is someone who doesn't
doesn't necessarily relish the attention
and I think it's pretty clear that he
feels bad that his employees got mixed
up into this and he didn't like that so
the main thing he all he wants to do
with chick-fil-a is just sell chicken on
a personal level he promotes Christian
values and traditional marriage and so
forth but as far as chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a his primary mission is just
to sell go chicken right and that's and
that's the point that he tried to make
but he never apologized for his beliefs
he explicitly was not apologizing for
believing in biblical marriage and when
given the opportunity he reasserted that
belief
so they have not won
came after him this all began in 2012
with Dan Kathy was asked in an interview
about his opinion about Trish nope
traditional marriage he says that he is
it is an advocate for it and that's what
all this started he is not backed down
from that even an inch
and so there's a great lesson there
that you've got this guy in this company
you know this guy runs a company he
comes out for traditional marriage
the the hounds of hell are unleashed to
go after him he sticks by his guns and
what's happened in the preceding six
years well only unprecedented growth and
enormous profitability for chick-fil-a
now chick-fil-a is even more popular
than it was before all this began so
stick to your guns
now of course I'm not saying that you
know as Christians
we aren't guaranteed to make out so well
when we voice our beliefs and stick to
them but Jesus tells us that you're
going to suffer you're going to be
persecuted so that clearly can happen
and does happen and will happen
but not always
it is possible
it is possible that you could stand up
for your beliefs and emerge from it
relatively unscathed
or even better off than you were before
that is possible the left once you
believe that's not possible
at any time you stand for your beliefs
you're sacrificing it's it's it's a
dangerous thing to do you're sacrificing
your livelihood your everything
everything you've worked for is gonna go
out the window now it is possible that
result could follow but not necessarily
and the main thing of course is whether
whatever happens to your company or
whatever happens to you financially you
still have your soul at the end of it
and that's what's important so that's a
really important lesson don't apologize
for your blue but the second lesson is
this gay marriage is the left most
sacred cow
and to oppose gay marriage is to commit
in their minds the unforgivable sin if
Dan Kathy had come out in favor of
strong borders or gun rights or
entitlement reform or tax reform or
whatever else the left probably would
have complained they would have been mad
about it but
it would not have they would not have
spent the last half decade trying to
ruin him for it
many companies and businesses have come
out and said we support guns we support
this now you can
they'll be mad at you but they'll move
on
I think he Dan Kathy could have even
come out as pro-life which I'm sure he
is pro-life and maybe he's even some
he's probably said so somewhere I don't
know but um he could have even come out
as pro-life and it would not have
provoked the same level of backlash as
does the gate the gay marriage thing
now abortion is still the left high
sacrament abortion is still the ultimate
high sacrament of liberalism it's
absolutely central to their doctrine of
moral relativism and so that's why it's
so important but
I think you're going to endure more fury
for dent defending biblical marriage
than for any other position including on
abortion
and this is why most Christians in
America even while they pretend to be
fighters against the left will not
breathe a word of opposition to gay
marriage and they will not publicly
defend the sexual morality of Scripture
they won't do it and as more and more of
these spineless Christians disavow these
positions the left becomes even more
vicious and hostile against those who
are the remaining few we will stick by
the their their beliefs
we've empowered the left by abandoning
this position we've just empowered them
um and now that there are so few people
who will oppose the gay agenda the left
is just when they encounter somebody
like that they're just shocked and
offended and appalled they're like what
you can but this position is so
unpopular you can't still be saying this
nobody else is saying you look around
even your own people have stopped saying
it how are you still saying it you can't
say that they're just indignant about it
they can't handle it and so they become
very bewildered and enraged and they
simply won't tolerate even a small
minority of dissenters on this point
they demand an absolute Universal
consensus on this issue that's what they
demand
not give it to them
truth is still the truth sin is still
sin marriage is still marriage and if
we're not going to defend those
propositions then we've already given up
the whole game
many conservatives today will say that
while opposing gay marriage defending
traditional marriage
it's pointless it doesn't matter it's
irrelevant it's not an important issue
well if it's so irrelevant and if it's
so unimportant then why is the left
trying so hard to eradicate this view
what is it so afraid of
if it's so important why can't they
tolerate even just a few people who have
no power anyway coming out against gay
marriage
I think the resistance is a clear
indication that this issue does matter
of course it matters it matters on two
levels first of all marriage is the
foundation of the family ends thus it is
the foundation of our civilization you
know marriage has two essential purposes
two components and that is its
procreative it can create children and
the other is that it's a bond a
permanent monogamous bond between man
and woman and it bonds them together in
love and devotion and sacrifice if we
categorically reject the essential
purpose of marriage and reject its
meaning if we deny those things then we
have fatally weakened this building
block upon which society rests that's
why it's so people say what's why is the
definition of marriage important because
marriage is is its it's the foundation
of our of our society that's why it's so
important what do you mean why is it
important
and there's a second point to sexual
immorality is a great scourge of modern
times and it has led a lot of people
into dark and despairing places
now the left's message is a hedonistic
one and thus it is a message that leads
people further into despair and we have
to have a counter vision we have to be
able to resist them on that front
and our counter vision is not simply
that gays shouldn't have sex it's one of
sexual morality is one of properly
ordering you know our sexuality
of having the proper purpose for
sexuality which is again to bond man and
woman together and also to create
we can't culturally speaking we cannot
give up on that
we sacrifice quite a bit
give up on that
we have to be able to still defend that
position
because if we don't then what's the
point if we give up on one of the
building blocks of civil of human
civilization then everything comes
coming to crumbling down there's no
point
the left's goal is to essentially
dismantle and reshape Western
civilization and that's why this is so
important to them and it's why we must
resist them and stick to the truth
just like chick-fil-a thanks for
watching thanks for listening everybody
Godspeed